N NOT GU
>>OORE, ALWARE
TO HAVE YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
SSICA?
CARRY OUTALD SO UA TOP WHITE H
ABOUT THION EARLIER TODAY
>> THE A WORD THAT COMES TO TT
IS LYING.THE UNITED STATES DIDN
HIISRE YOU THE UNITED
STATES HAD NO ROLE IN IT
WHAT>> STRONG
ADMINISTRATION TRE, THOUGHITAY D
UT
I A PRETEXT FORRETA UNLEASHINGR
OTIN
T ONDEN
HAD ES ON THEM.
CNN'S NICKONIN UKIN S
WORSATW RY
IT SEEMS THAT  SIDES ARE .
>>epTAINLY,
N SEEING IS  CREASETEMP
STRIKES OFTEN HITTINVILIAN
THE WORST SINCTHE YEAR B.G THATF
LAST NIGHT, MANY DRONEN  OSKY,O
HE SOUTH OF TH
COUNTRY.
COMPARED TO PREVIOUE SEEN CITIE
ST NOT T WORST, T
RECENTLYPIERS, 24 LOST THEIR T P
CENTERND RAILWAY STATION.
BEING HITLI
N'T REALLATION UKRNIE ABOUT.WHH
EY RESERVEASSINATION BY
E RIGHT TOTE, SPOKES INT
ECESSARILYAID THATTI
ON TODAY. W IN RMS OF WO BITOBA
RUSSIAN RESPE'S TE
FR U.ALL RIGHT.NITE
THANYOU SO MFOR
'S FIGURE OUW EDE CLAI.,AVE SO
G ME NOW, WE HAV
A THING OR TWOBOIS, RETIREADIER
STEVE ANDERSON.
TO GET TO THE AIHIS N E
KREMLIN, LET'S S
OF UKRAINIANN
IT FAR.ORDER OFAINE,
CRLE UNIRITORYALRA FROM E, DOW
ISE 30LE --
DRAW A STRAIGHLI
HOW EDS TH CREDIBLE.
WAY THINKN DRONESE O  O
SOPICENS
W
50OM KYIV L TOOSCOW, IT' NIN
RIO
REASONABLE.
>> AND I AIR ULARLYOTEAHERE.
Y.
THEY'D BFO MOSCOW,
THIBLY
EFFICIENT ANR
TO FLYD SQRECURRED WASN , 35 YEE
BUT SINCE THENITTTY
ING TO BINCREDIBLY.
>>OOK AT THEES.S WH
M LISTTHIS WELME
THEY'VE BEEN HITTING KHANLY A F,
CLOS TERRITORY DOW
BACK FROM RUSSIAY
AND OF COURSTAL,
LOT OF TALK ABOUTARGETINE
UKRAINPRYR
ARES>> THEREIGY LL
OULD BE D VERY WORRIED A
YOU KNOWFLI THAT WTACKN THE KRB.
ECY DETAILZELENSKYY'
DEFINILY M.
YOU KNOWING OP, TERRORIZINENT, -
BEEN PLAYING
THIS WHOLE THING.
TH TY RE P
>> MLA BE A MADISON ATTACKCLAIM
RUF D TO BKRAINIAN
ES I A
ILLENNIANCK
BYSSOUT  HAD A MAD
ANOTHEPOR TH
IG
IYOUR>> AE RT
UAISTANCERAINE  IT'S GOT
NOING  DDO YELT CLAIM?
L
NOTHING TOE IT'SED B
S  A  OPARTISANS, T WOSE
THDRONES.AVE TOBLECEKELY BUT ITE
SHNG OK, GET
CMOSCOW, PERHAPS PULL
THEE KIND
COULD HAPPEN, BUT ITPRETTY
A
>> PAR THAT FALSAG